her new movie vice has an early lead
this award season with six nominations
for Golden Globes the dark comedy charts
the rise of Dick Cheney to become the
most powerful Vice President in history
the movie reunites actor Christian Bale
who plays Cheney with Adam McKay who
directed Bale in the big short we spoke
with them in Los Angeles I want you to
be my VP I want you you my vice vice
spans 50 years of Dick Cheney's rise to
power the vice presidency is a mostly
symbolic job the film portrays Cheney is
a shrewd political operative however if
we came to a different understanding the
idea for Vice happened by accident down
with the flu director Adam McKay picked
up a book on Cheney I started reading it
I was like oh my god I saw a love story
there I saw an arc of ambition at which
point do you start thinking about
Christian while you're writing it or
while you're reading it when Dick
Cheney's described as a man lacking any
charisma no one has shown the world the
true
the American presidency I saw a change
in America I saw fear paranoia are you
even more ruthless than used to be
intrigued McKay kept reading 18 books in
all he said to gain insight into the man
who pushed for the invasion of Iraq in
2003 and backed the most aggressive
measures for pursuing terrorists at home
and abroad Adam you've talked a lot
about power is power and actor in this
play or is power kind of coursing
through it it was one of the things that
drew me to the story
how does power affect human beings Dick
Cheney was a guy through very quiet
brilliant means of understanding how our
elaborate government works took on this
incredible amount of power while never
having to stand in front of the
spotlight really he claims to have
absolutely zero regrets he's very
strong-minded and he will not back down
ever having worked with bail on the big
short McKay had him in mind while
writing vice to play the former VP bail
shaved his head and packed on some 40
pounds half the room wants to be us the
other half fearsome famous for physical
transformations in 2004 Bale lost 60
pounds to play an insomniac in The
Machinist only to bulk back up the
following year to play Bruce Wayne in
Batman Begins in 2010 he slimmed down
and took home a supporting Oscar for the
fighter then shaved his head and gained
a paunch for American hustle Bale
attacks every role with the same
intensity
how long do the characters stay in your
head do they ever leave I don't know I
mean do you have moments of Chaney that
do that still happen it sounds odd but
you do a little bit yes like Mackay Bale
studied Chaney from the tiniest details
to the big ones like suffering multiple
heart attacks how do you learn to play
somebody having a heart attack I went in
and got a wonderful cardiologist to act
now you didn't want to do it initially
and then I convinced him I said come on
let's get on our feet and can you show
me the different extremes you know from
the clutch into the just sort of strange
feeling in my stomach and I had him
actually act it all out for me so then I
just stole his performance and there put
it in the film did you have to go
somewhere in practice having heart
attacks oh you do that you just so walk
around and then do it and you know you
look you always look a bit mental when
you're an actor and maybe it's right you
are a bit mental you know I came out
I'll be doing things not realizing it
and then my son will look at me as I'm
talking to myself for pretending to have
a heart attack and he said daddy please
stop doing that action during production
McKay says he smokes heavily and
overrate like Chaney who reportedly ate
a dozen donuts and smoked three packs a
day early in his career when the filming
ended Adam tried to get back in shape
then I had like tingly hands but my
stomach was queasy and I think we all
think of heart attack as chest pain arm
pain so I told my trainer I was like I'm
fine
don't worry about it and the second he
left I remembered this fella telling me
like how do you want the heart attack
you want like queasy stuff look and I
ran upstairs and took four baby aspirin
and called 911
and when I got to the doctor he's like
why did you do that and I said my weed
after it that was a symptom he's like
well because you did that you have no
damage to your heart but if you'd phoned
in your character hadn't gone to the
cardiologist hadn't figured out hadn't
gone deep you wouldn't know where you go
and I saved his life like yes yeah
Wow that was good that was really good
acting led to more than just a good
performance and the fact that Adam could
see Christian Bale in that role genius
that's right